you write about modeling of uh
mathematical cognition so let me first
ask about mathematics in general
there's a paper
titled parallel distributed processing
approach to mathematical cognition where
in the introduction there's some
beautiful
discussion of mathematics
and you reference there tristan needham
who criticizes a narrow formal view of
mathematics by
liking the studying of mathematics as
symbol manipulation to studying music
without ever hearing a note
so from that perspective
what do you think is mathematics what is
this world of mathematics like well i
think of mathematics as
a set of tools for
exploring
idealized
worlds
that um
often turn out to be
extremely relevant to the real world but
need not um
but there are worlds in which
objects exist with
idealized properties
and
in which
the relationships among them can be
characterized with precision
so as to allow
the implications of
certain facts to then allow you to
derive other facts with certainty
so
you know
if
you have two
triangles
and you know that there is um
uh
an angle in the first one that has the
same measure as an angle in the second
one and you know that the lengths of the
sides
to that angle in each of the two
triangles
the corresponding sides adjacent to that
angle are
also have the same measure then you can
then conclude that the triangles
are
congruent that is to say they have all
of their properties in common
and and that
is something about
triangles it's not
a
matter of formulas these are idealized
objects
in fact
you know we built bridges out of
triangles and
we understand
how to measure the height of something
we can't climb by
um extending these ideas about triangles
a little further
and
you know
all of the ability to um
get a tiny
speck of matter launched from
uh the planet earth to intersect with
some tiny tiny little body way out in
way beyond pluto somewhere
exactly a predicted time and date is
is something that depends on these ideas
right so
but and it's actually uh
happening
in the real physical world that these
ideas
make contact with it uh in those kinds
of instances
um
and um
so
but you know there are these idealized
objects these triangles or these
distances or these points whatever they
are
that um
uh allow for this um set of tools to be
created that then
gives human beings the uh is this
incredible leverage that they didn't
have without these concepts
and uh i think this is actually already
true
[Music]
when we think about
just
you know
the
natural numbers
um i always like to include zero so i'm
gonna say
the non-negative integers but
that's that's the place where some
people prefer not to include zero but uh
now we like zero here natural numbers
zero one two three four five six seven
and so on yeah
and and you know because they give you
the ability to
um
be
exact
about
um
like how many sheep you have like you
know i sent you out this morning there
were 23 sheep you came back with only
22. what happened yeah right
the fundamental problem of physics how
many sheep you have
yeah it's a fundamental problem of life
of human uh society that you damn well
better bring back the same number of
sheep as you started with
uh and you know it allows commerce it
allows um
contracts it allows the establishment of
uh records and so on to have systems
that allow these things to be notated
but they they have um
an inherent aboutness to them that's at
this one at the one in the same time
sort of abstract and idealized and
generalizable while at the other on the
other hand um
potentially very very grounded and
concrete
and
one of the things that
makes
for the
incredible
achievements of the human mind is
the fact that humans invented these
idealized systems that
leverage
the power of human thought
in such a way as to allow all this kind
of thing to happen
and and so that's
what mathematics to me is the
development of systems for thinking
about
uh the properties and relations among uh
sets of
idealized objects and um
uh
you know the the mathematical notation
system that
we
unfortunately focus way too much on is
um
just our way of
expressing
uh propositions about these properties
right it's just just like we're talking
with chomsky and language
it's the thing we've invented for the
communication of those ideas they're not
necessarily
the deep representation of those ideas
yeah so what um
what's uh what's a good way to model
such
powerful mathematical
reasoning would you say what what are
some ideas you have for capturing this
in a model
the insights that human mathematicians
have had is
a combination of the kind of the
intuitive
kind of
connectionist like knowledge that makes
it so that
something
is just
like obviously true
so that you don't have to think about
why it's true
that then makes it possible
to then
take the next step
and ponder and reason and figure out
something that you previously didn't
have that intuition about
it then ultimately becomes
a part of the intuition that
the next generation of
mathematical thinkers have to ground
their own thinking on so that they can
extend the ideas even further
i came across this quotation
from i'll replace while i was
walking
in the
in the woods with my wife in a state
park in northern california late last
summer
and what it said on the bench was
it is by
logic that we prove but by intuition
that we discover and so what what for me
the the essence of the of the project
is to understand how to bring the
intuitive connectionist
resources to bear on
letting
the
intuitive discovery arise
uh
you know from
engagement in thinking with this formal
system
so i i think of
you know
the
ability of somebody like hinton or
newton or einstein or
romal heart or poincare to
um
archimedes is another example right so
suddenly a flash of insight occurs
it's it's like
the
constellation of all of these
simultaneous constraints that somehow or
other causes the mind to settle into a a
novel state that it never did before and
and give rise to a new idea
um that
you know then
you can say okay well now how can i
prove this you know how do i write down
the steps of that theorem that that'll
allow me to make it rigorous and certain
and so
i feel like the
the kinds of things that we're beginning
to see
deep learning systems
do of their own accord
kind of gives me
this feeling of
of um
i don't know hope or
encouragement that
ultimately
um it'll all uh
happen
um so in particular as
many people now have have
become really interested in thinking
about
you know neural networks that have been
trained with massive amounts of
text
can be given a prompt and they can then
sort of generate some
really interesting fanciful creative
story from that prompt
um and uh
there's there's kind of like a sense
that they've somehow synthesized
something
like novel out of the
you know all of the particulars of all
of the billions and billions of
experiences that went into the training
data
that that gives rise to something like
this sort of intuitive sense of what
would be a
a fun and interesting little story to
tell or something like that it just sort
of wells up out of the
out of the
letting the thing play out its own
imagining of what
somebody might say given this prompt as
a as a input to get it to to start to
generate
its own thoughts
and and to me that that sort of
represents the potential of capturing
this the intuitive side of this
yeah and there's other examples i don't
know if you find them as captivating is
you know on the deep mind side with
alpha zero
if you study chess the kind of solutions
that has come up in terms of chess it is
it
there's novel ideas there it feels very
uh like there's brilliant moments of
insight and the
mechanism they use
if you think of search as
as maybe more towards good old-fashioned
ai and and then there's the
connectionist the you know network that
has the intuition of
looking at a board looking at a set of
patterns and saying how good is this set
of positions and the next few positions
how good are those and that's it no
that's just an intuition
uh yeah great grandmasters have this and
understanding positionally tactically
how good the situation is how can it be
improved without doing this full
like deep search
um
and then maybe doing a little bit of the
what human chess players call
calculation which is the search
taking a particular set of steps down
the line to see how they unroll but
there there is moments of genius in
those systems
too so that's another
hopeful illustration
that from neural networks can emerge
this novel
creation of an idea
yes and i think that
you know i think demas asabus is um
you know he's spoken about those things
he uh i heard him
describe a
move that was made in in one of the
go matches against lisa doll in this
very in a very similar way and
um it caused me to become really excited
to
kind of collaborate with some of those
guys at deepmind
um
so
i think though that what
what i like to really emphasize
here is
one part of what i like to emphasize
about mathematical cognition at least is
that
philosophers
and logicians
going back
three or even
a little more than 3000 years ago
began to develop
these formal systems
and
gradually
the
whole idea about thinking formally
got constructed um
and you know it's preceded euclid
um
certainly present in the work of thales
and others and i'm not
the world's leading expert in all the
details of that history
but euclid's
elements were the
the kind of the touch point of a
of a coherent document that sort of laid
out this
idea of an actual formal system within
which
these objects were characterized and the
um
the system of
inference
that
allowed
new truths to be derived from others was
sort of like established as a paradigm
and
what
what i
find interesting is
the idea that
the ability to become
a person who is capable of thinking
in this abstract formal way
is
you know a result of the same kind of
immersion
uh
in
in experience
thinking in that way that you know we
now begin to think of our understanding
of language as being right so
we immerse ourselves in
in a particular language
in a particular world of objects in
their relationships and we learn to talk
about that
and we develop intuitive understanding
of the real world in in a similar way we
can think that
what
academia
has created for us what you know those
early philosophers and their
academies in
athens and alexandria and others other
places
allowed was the
development of these
schools of thought modes of thought that
that then become deeply ingrained and
you know
it it becomes what it is that makes it
so that somebody like jerry fodor would
think
that
um
systematic thought is
the essential characteristic of the
human mind as opposed to
a derived
and an acquired characteristic that
results from acculturation in a certain
mode
that's been invented by humans
you